you work to Spike Lee on school days do
the right thing early stuff money's
career when you walk on the set of
school days and you're doing do the
right thing did you realize that the
time [ __ ] this guy is really talented
oh are you kidding me spike it was
always had a very demonstrative attitude
knew what he wanted and I thought he
always was doing something very
different than I had ever imagined the
director would do first you know in the
early days that label of his oh well
he's just trying to be different but
then I realized his knowledge of film is
deep and the folks that he likes
directors he likes and admires and
remembers those shots are and and does
omage is in different movies to those
directors are what he was inspired by so
spike inspired me because he's so
himself even today you know to me Spike
Lee's is bigger than the sum of all of
his parts because he's committed to a
social agenda that he has for African
American people because he wants the
world to be better for them so he opens
doors for other people and he opens
doors socially and politically that
haven't been open before but tell us his
stories in a way that really strike a
chord with human beings so walking on
those sets and at that time I always
knew he had such strong ideas but yet a
guy who has such strong ideas as a
director could still be open to me doing
something spontaneously that may tickle
his fancy you may like so I always play
games with him and do things there that
are inspiring to me because I feel them
oh I should do that why do I feel that
way well you got to follow your gut do
it and then it's a long pause all the
other actors like I don't believe he
just went off the script you just said
these lines Spike Lee is sitting there
scratching his head for a second with a
bullhorn on the ladder schooldays dr.
spera I didn't like our lines Larry said
what we're gonna do I said well we just
rewrite it at lunch he's like be kidding
me Spike's gonna kill us so something
cares there's you know fifty hundred
people on the quad other actors are we
gonna get embarrassed but I might forget
it let's go rewrite it you wrote it came
out after lunch Rosa action wait a
minute cut cut
wait who said that who said that I did
spy
I like say it again you know and other
times na na-na-na Carla - expository -
story - explanatory no say what I wrote
say without room say what I wrote right
but this is how we find the level of how
far can we push the envelope what rings
true for me and what makes for true for
you as an auteur spike - no - or does
wonderful work allows people to be
themselves and if you're brave enough
with any human being to be able to speak
your mind and not feel threatened by
then you find some new ground sometimes
in between sometimes he takes it
sometimes he doesn't I love what he does
Godfather world
thanks I absolutely adore being a part
of Chris Mikado and I have been trying
to work together for 20 years ever since
he was back writing for Las Vegas and a
few other shows that I never was able to
connect with him on we had a meeting
about doing
narcos he was there in the first season
it's an incredible job with padilla they
both collaborated on getting that show
off the ground and this particular show
came up at the last minute he didn't
think I was available you know he's the
guy that picks the head of epics was a
wonderful gentleman was saying hey who's
gonna play this role Adam Clayton Powell
jr. historical figure on 25th Street is
Adam Clayton Powell jr. Boulevard he was
a preacher at Abyssinian Baptist Church
he was a congressman he was he assigned
more bills to this day on the record
than any congressman ever in history the
things that he did you'd be shocked by
one is the minimum wage act the evil
Equal Opportunity Employment Act the the
funding for the National Endowment of
the Arts this man was quite amazing so
when I was approached about doing this
role playing with actors like Forest
Whitaker who's playing bumpy Ellsworth
Johnson it is his story coming out of
prison in San Francisco coming back to
Harlem ten years later to figure out how
to wrestle the drug and prostitution
trade away from the Italians this is a
show that I think people are really
waiting for as well because you get a
cross-section of what America was like
in the 60s politically and also
personally and
so through the eye of some great
mobsters Vincent D'Onofrio plays the
chin Gigante in this and he has an
absolutely amazing performance he's what
we call a talented actor very talented
actor jazz commentaries on our show Paul
Sorvino so you get a real feeling that
we have communities of African Americans
communities of Italians communities of
just poor people and how Malcolm X is in
our show so historically it is a show
about what really happened in Harlem at
this particular time and I play a
character that I feel has allowed me to
be even looser than many characters I
played because the guy was just such a
larger-than-life figure and dealing with
the Dixiecrats in Washington you get a
sense of where our world was at at that
time and how it evolved and changed to
be something different which is a mirror
for where we're at now in the state of
politics and personalities in America
right now I can't express in words how
impressed I am with Vince and what he's
been able to do we better call Saul
because he makes it look easy when it is
so impossible to do what he does and
make this the writing is so phenomenal
the direction I am there's no weak link
in terms of what he's done in each other
he made a spinoff sorry for going on but
like he took what could be you know this
amazing show and then he made a spin-off
that's arguably as good you know it's
unbelievable what did you think I just
have to ask you about what it's like
working with him and the quality of the
writing everything about better call
Saul has been for me just exceptional
well things come from the top you know
you have exceptional writing number one
but you also have some a person who is
the nicest guy ever want to meet he's
also humble and he's also very well
thought-out
in his plans for his show and you know
this takes a certain essence of what
someone is about you know he is about
telling a great story and he's about
mining relationships between people and
situations that allow that story to be
told seamlessly and allow you you know
takes the time like I was never before
on a show I think was in season four or
five of Breaking Bad where we're gonna
move the schedule because we want to
take more time really sussing out these
episodes well that would make a network
or a person like me feel like oh they're
not ready what do you mean well they
were completely ready but they want it
to be even more than ready they want it
to really link up all the things that
they have ideas to link up and haven't
figure it out yet so these guys are like
it's a puzzle for us but they find a way
because they put in that time
thoughtfulness so I never feel like I'm
left hanging out to dry when my
character has a thought or a feeling or
a stage direction is written that I
don't back down I mean anger with anger
or I mean anger with compassion but
there's something else behind that
compassion because I'm already seeing
the route I'm gonna go to take you out
of your anger and make you do what I
want you to do the space Vince allows
space to be able to be inspired by the
actor and what he's doing with the
writing that he's creating and he's
passed this on in his collaboration with
Peter Gould and he's passed on by in my
observance of what he does and what they
do allows me to feel trust so yeah it
feels like a whole lot of brain how
could I think about all those things but
it's very specific and it's well mind
and it's well informed by what's
happened before and that to me is is
really a beautiful thing you can go back
in your head and go to episode 6 of
Breaking Bad
Saul Goodman said this and this really
plays into what we want to portray and
pull out of his character in five oh one
of better call Saul yeah and so that is
just really being conscious of what
you've created before and how to create
that link not trying to be fantastical
not trying to be try to to exemplify
something that is is not complete
already where you're filming right now
yes we started this week I was gonna say
which is awesome because I heard it
doesn't come back till 2020 and I was
like it's the quality of the show I'm
willing to wait for you know it's just
so well done well you know the shows get
get scheduled as they do and you know
this question was asked by my lovely joy
mother of my children yesterday why 2020
well we're looking with 2019 where it's
it's you know it's April we'll finish in
August September they'll do the editing
until January and we're 2020 man what's
the problem I think that oftentimes
people are chasing release dates rather
than making the best possible version of
their story and putting listen
gameofthrones waited a year and a half
however long it's been since the last
season people will tune in people will
tune in you know you do have the we used
to have the problem of network
television losing your audience and they
changing beyond I've had that problem a
couple of times they put you on a Monday
night first season and you're doing
great and then or you put your honor
then you're on Friday when everyone's
going out because you just didn't draw
those numbers no those are dictated by
of course executives who what you don't
want to draw the best audience out of
things but tell what has changed since
then you know and people will wait I
have people would solve who aren't gonna
watch one episode - all the episodes
have aired and done so they can just
watch it all like a movie I have to ask
you because I know I'm just about out of
time is the fifth season the last season
I'm confused like or is there more do
you were you know to be with Vince
because he likes to you know if you look
at the Breaking Bad model you know he
said five years five seasons of them we
shot that fifth season but it was really
five and six sure and then he broken
into a six so you know in telling the
story you know it's always difficult to
find the ending of what is supposed to
be but then there is another ending of
what could be or what you imagined
things to be after the ending has
concluded yeah the thing that's
interesting is that as he told you and I
obviously don't want
but his he told you how you asked it uh
how it's all let going do you know where
like the ending of this thing is or is
he have you been like just no I don't
and nor do I want to all right so it's
script by script for you it's script by
script for me I could get an idea of
what may happen is an overall you know
feeling maybe for the could get a little
bit of sense but hardly even that I mean
we're so trustworthy these actors that
we feel hey Peter Goyal said it great at
a panel last week what would you would
you like that to happen cuz I'd like us
to do them Oh what would you like to
happen you know and I thought about it I
said Matic - yeah you know what's
interesting is you have the script for
5:01 the script of 5:01 tells you a lot
because ever the first episode of every
season is very informative on certain
things precisely and so you you have
more knowledge right now about where
ultimately it could be go I certainly do
you know there is a new character coming
in Lalo Salamanca obviously something
I'm gonna have to deal with in my
travels throughout the show there will
be six seasons it seems like that's the
way the the comfortable way to end this
show I am hoping for a more of a
collaboration in some way as an artist
with Bob Odenkirk I know as my star
grows as Gus fring to be able to handle
some of the edginess of the show more
and more and as Jean you know goes it
comes to Saul Goodman and he becomes
this a nefarious lawyer that I'll have
more interaction with excited about that
completely my last thing for you
although I have a million things to talk
about you didn't have some Creepshow yes
I did wow that's Greg Nicotero
yeah I was really nice to work his grit
with Greg Nicotero I work with him
previously on my four oh four thirteen
episode of Breaking Bad where it was
called two faiths where I lose half my
face yeah yes Greg's an amazing artist
amazing artist he did that work Howard
Berger came into the application also
designed it with Greg Academy
award-winner
I'm really really conscious of artistry
in any form it comes
that we work with Craig's a director
known he's very good and respected and
sure enough he is very different genre
yeah I wanted to go have fun he called
me sick when I come have some fun and do
a Creepshow piece and I was like oh wow
I was in Europe you know sick my
girlfriend and we were trying to find a
horror movie and then he's on my phone
saying hey I'm like are you serious you
know and it's something iconic you know
George Romero Creepshow you know Adrian
robos in the original she came to play
with us as well so I'm excited about
that didn't realize how draining it can
be to go through the emotions of being
in fear draining to show the emotions of
truly being afraid to show the intention
of truly want a figure figure a way out
of that fear and of playing with an
entity that is just so slimy and so
grossest so we're here it ought to be is
like a whole different deal know I've
spoken to a lot of actors you say that
like they get home from set when they're
doing stuff like that and they are tired
I just need to land my bed and do
nothing that's right because emotionally
you're drawn out you're drained you're
waiting for something to happen as an
actor when something happens there's no
lights and and you know Greg was like oh
yeah because there's a whole big beat
between me and Tobin the actor who was
my scene partner but who would have the
flashlight it's written that my
character doc has the flashlight
well then we get into the house and
Tobin's like yeah yeah okay I should
have a flashlight too no I don't want
the class line yeah why do you have a
flashlight as I have the flashlight then
all the lights go out and the camera
rolls and the flashlight I have in my
hand is his light and my life and so
Greg says to me hey you know you didn't
know you'd be the DP as well did you and
the DP is like the light feel a little
bit here phille over there and I'm gonna
be standing here with a white card I'm
like dudes I got dialog man yeah I'll do
the best I can to hit that board hit
that board hit myself you know like the
whole seat for everybody well I'm going
to say them with digital cameras now
what's amazing about them but I love you
bolon know is you can the lower light
situations are much easier to handle
with these newer digital cameras yes
they are easier to handle and have much
more clarity than otherwise but I always
remind the DP I'm a little more swarthy
than
folks in the scene so therefore the
white cards came out but it was
wonderful cuz I'm a filmmaker you know
I've made tuned filters director first
ones call gospel Hill the second was
called the show both with all-star cast
both can be seen somewhere on your
on-demand channels but so I know how
special it is to be able to figure out
what kind of light you want to see on
your actors and I know how particular
that that is but to be able to do to
play with Greg Nicotero for three or
four days where it is again feels like
guerrilla filmmaking feels like advanced
filmmaking because of discovery
completely and that discovery is one